zuerst einmal ist die grundsätzliche
vereinbarung wie folgt wir starten jetzt
in den ersten beiden wochen also nächste
und übernächste woche mit beyond
ausschließlich für die arztpraxen und
dann ab der kw 16 der woche danach wird
biontech und astra zenica gehen die
arztpraxen gehen und ab kalenderwoche 17
um es noch komplexer zu machen
beyonce kastration iker und johnson &
johnson in die arztpraxen gehen ob es
aufgrund der entwicklung der letzten
tage da noch anpassungen gibt das müssen
wir noch mal mit den ländern erörtern
aber grundsätzlich ist dass das vorgehen
dass wir auch vereinbart haben und
deswegen ist es richtig und auch
notwendig dass natürlich die länder die
impfstoff dosen von astrazeneca die sie
noch bekommen nämlich jetzt am
wochenende 1,17 millionen dosen und dann
in den beiden folgewochen
zusammengenommen auch noch mal gut
700.000 dosen dass die natürlich auch
vererbt werden in den ländern
und das ist ja jetzt auch teil der
impfkampagne
sie haben nordrhein-westfalen
angesprochen die jetzt dort auch
stattfinden unser ziel ist dass jede
impfdosen geliefert wird auch
schnellstmöglich verimpft wird und da
sind wir uns nicht nur bei den
impfzentren sondern vor allem bei den
arztpraxen auch sehr sicher dass das was
zu wochenbeginn in zwei biontech
geliefert wird der ablauf wird immer
seien zu wochenbeginn wird ausgeliefert
dann auch bis ende der woche verlässt
ist und das ist bei biontech auch
notwendig weil eben nur wenige tage bis
zum ende woche ziemlich exakt paar tage
länger im notfall der impfstoff auch bei
kühlschranktemperatur gelagert werden
kann
aber es ist eben auch möglich und das
ist denke ich auch das ansehen so kenne
ich die ärztinnen und ärzte dann wenn
der impfstoff in der praxis ist ihnen
auch schnellstmöglich zu verhelfen also
der switch das war ja ihre frage ist
weniger von im zentrum zu arztpraxen
wird im laufe des aprils erfolgen so ist
es mit den ländern vereinbart
zuerst einmal ist ganz wichtig weil es
stellen sich etwa zwei millionen
menschen in deutschland genau diese
frage was ist
meine zweite impfung übrigens ist mir
auch noch mal sehr wichtig als botschaft
die ja auch als paul ehrlich institut
die stiko andere gemacht haben wenn
überhaupt nicht sagte noch einmal es ist
sehr selten wenn überhaupt dann ist das
etwas was im vierten bis zum 16 tag nach
der impfung beobachtet wurde also wer
vor drei oder fünf wochen geimpft wurde
muss ich jetzt nicht da besorgen
und wer in diesem zeitraum geimpft wurde
zurückliegend sollte einfach sozusagen
aufpassen auf bestimmte merkmale starken
kopfschmerz bestimmte veränderungen
blutflecken und dann schnellstmöglich
den arzt kontaktieren sehr selten aber
eben ernst zu nehmen und bei den zweit
impfungen die frage stellen sich jetzt
natürlich viele was ist damit
es ist wichtig zu sehen wir haben in
deutschland begonnen anfang februar mit
astra zenica zu impfen
das empfohlene intervall für die
zweitimpfung sind neun bis zwölf wochen
wir haben mittlerweile übrigens auch
jeden tag wächst die erkenntnis gute
studiendaten das geld längere intervalle
die wirksamkeit sogar erhöht also nach
zwölf wochen sogar ist besser ist als
neun wochen zwölf wochen bis anfang mai
wo die ersten zwei impfungen sozusagen
idealerweise spätestens stattfinden
sollten
und deswegen bitte ich jetzt einfach um
geduld ich hätte würde die frage auch
gerne schon abschließend beantworten
können
aber die zeit können wir uns jetzt auch
nehmen weil eben nichts passiert
sozusagen von der schutzwirkung der
erstimpfung geht nichts verloren jetzt
innerhalb dieses zeitraums des aprils
bis dahin hat die ständige
impfkommission gesagt wird sie uns eine
antwort zu geben versuchen jedenfalls
auf basis der vorliegenden evidenz in
einigen ländern haben ja studien schon
begonnen
auch zu dieser zu dieser frage mir ist
nur eine botschaft wichtig wir werden
jedem bundesbürger auch denjenigen wie
eine erste impfung mit astra zenica
haben für sich entscheiden nicht auch
die zweite funktion es gibt ja die
meldung habe ich schon bekommen aus den
letzten zwei tagen durchaus welche die
sagen ich mache meine zweite impfung
nach entsprechender aufklärung
informationen und herr gassen wird es
auch machen und und diejenigen die sich
anders entscheiden oder wo es eine
bestimmte vor disposition gibt wir
werden sicherstellen dass jeder
bundesbürger der will ein vollen
impfschutz bekommt und ein impfschema
das diesen vollen impfschutz garantiert
und sei es indem wir ein neues im schema
beginnen aber idealerweise finden wir
heraus und findet die wissenschaft
heraus dass auch ein anderer impfstoff
zu entsprechendem schutz als zweite
impfstoff führt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren